I don't think they work right now but
the point is that after G takes F6 Queen
87 would have been a check Magnus plays
Queen 87 first and the eval bar does not
like this move it says equal I think you
were right and look Madness is now worse
he made two inaccuracies in a row he's
going for the G7 Pawn but after Pawn
takes Bishop takes E5 he's hitting this
Knight and G7 but can this Knight simply
Retreat back to H5 here if Madness
completely missed that oh he did look at
him he's shaking his head he is busted
the queen comes to F3 threatening Queen
D1 check and defending the King on the
f-file which means that what can white
even do here the bishop has no squares
vinegar's wrathi about to win with black
against Magnus Carlson this is resign
time it's easy now and there is a
resignation we saw the Eva bar Up Up and
Away that in this moment here Bishop
takes F6 was in fact a winning move if
you take with the pawn queen H7 skewers
the queen on B7